[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
ex-nickelodeon star drink bell is
sentenced to probation for inappropriate
contact with a minor
the young girl calling for a higher
sentence the actor
apologizing i accept this plea because
my conduct was wrong
the defense case of a colorado father
accused of murdering his own son
mark redwine's expert witness and the
tough cross-examination
plus the new lawsuit filed in the briana
taylor case claiming police may be lying
about the existence of body cam video
from the deadly raid and the giant
misunderstanding
an arsenal of weapons found near the mlb
all-star game site
officials saying this was not a mass
shooting attempt
that is the number one lesson for all of
us is if you
see something say something law and
crime daily covering court cases from
coast to coast
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin
former nickelodeon star drake bell is
sentenced to two years
of probation to crimes against a minor
but the then 15 year old victim is
calling him a pedophile
and says she believes he should have
received the maximum sentence
jared drake bell pled guilty last month
to attempted child endangerment and
disseminating matter harmful to
juveniles
immediately he took to instagram to
perform live for his 4 million followers
[Music]
bell was arrested for inappropriate
contact with a 15 year old girl
we are not identifying her because of
her age in court the young woman said
she was groomed for years by belle that
he took advantage of her because
she was a super fan and that the two
exchanged sexual messages and nude
photos
she says it escalated in december 2017
when her aunt took her to bell's concert
in cincinnati
that night the defendant took me
backstage to be alone with him
he started kissing me and the night
ended and
him having me perform oral sex on him
twice
the next incident happened on december
2nd 2017
while i was alone with him in his hotel
room
he had talked to me about seeing me one
last time before we all left cleveland
and went home
so we went to his hotel to say goodbye
in his hotel room
he started kissing me and had me perform
oral sex on him again
my aunt was right outside the room
waiting in the hallway while this was
happening
she says she's now traumatized and asked
the judge not to let him get away with
it
just because he's famous if he is truly
sorry for anything
he is sorry that he has finally been
caught
i can assure you of that he committed
these crimes against me
with pride a defendant who clearly feels
no remorse for his crimes deserves to be
given the maximum sentence possible
i will never forget what he did to me i
idolized and looked up to him
and he took that and broke it in the
most sickening way possible
he is the epitome of evil
i deserved better than to be used for
his sick desires
and for my suffering to be used for his
amusement
jared drake bell is a pedophile and that
is his legacy
bell's attorney then took aim at the
victim's credibility calling her claims
that they exchanged photos
unfounded we went through these claims
with the prosecutor's office for a long
time approximately 18 months
no such image was presented
either to the state or to the defense
the
claim that he has a pedophile
lacks any sort of factual support uh
from the case
and it also lacks any sort of mental
health claim it's an easy
tag to give someone but
doesn't fit in this case
bell's attorney went on to explain that
bella's only accepting responsibility
for chats between the defendant and the
victim including one
that he told the girl to hurry up after
learning she was a minor
bell then apologized in court
i accept this plea because my conduct
was wrong
i'm sorry that the victim was harmed in
any way but that was obviously not my
intention
i have taken this matter very very
seriously
um
and again i just want to apologize to
her and
and uh
anyone else who may have been affected
by my actions
a grown man does not engage in
inappropriate text messages
to a teenager i i hope you truly are
remorseful i don't know
you are going to get one year on the
felony four
six months on the misdemeanor that'll
run concurrent by operation of law
i will suspend the imposition of the
sentence you will be uh subject to two
years community control sanctions
joining us today is criminal defense
attorney bernardo villalona and terry
austin
bernardo what do you expect probation
will look like for bell
so what is probation probation is a
court order that the judge has given in
community
supervised supervision so what's going
to look like for him
i'm sure of probably they're going to be
checking on him at his home they can pop
up at any time
he's going to have to report to
probation at least one time a month
maybe they'll give him a curfew
maybe they'll do drug tests on him maybe
they'll put him in some kind of program
that they think would be beneficial to
him but what i tell you this
is that if he violates any of the terms
of probation
he can be facing going back to jail
absolutely terry
is this sentence just a slap on the
wrist should the prosecution and judge
have listened to the victim's request
at the end of the day for more time
there's no question that this was
definitely a slap on the wrist even the
sentence that the judge originally
imposed the one year for
the attempted child endangerment and the
six months
for disseminating matter that was
harmful to a child that is low
as far as the scheme of things is
concerned so
that was suspended and now he's only
going to serve
two years probation so even though it
seemed as if
the defendant was remorseful he said all
the right words
but we heard the judge say he wasn't
sure if that was sincere and frankly he
didn't seem sincere to me either
all right so there it is for drake bell
getting two years of probation
for the allegations no longer but for
the crime of disseminating materials to
a
minor thank you both turning now to
other top legal news
federal prosecutors want the identities
of r kelly's alleged victims
to remain secret the assistant u.s
attorney for the eastern district of new
york
filing the motion over the weekend five
weeks before the start of the disgraced
r b
singer's trial on charges he trafficked
and sexually abused
multiple young women including minors
the prosecutor says the decision is
reasonable necessary and appropriate to
protect the safety
and well-being of the women r kelly's
trial begins august 18th
he's also being trialed on separate sex
abuse charges in chicago
and in texas a now former atlanta
falcons linebacker is facing charges
for sexually abusing a teenage boy
police in arlington filing the charges
over the weekend
they say the incident happened in the
summer of 2019
but they learned about it in january
when the boy's mother contacted them
authorities say the athlete invited a
teen family member and another teen to
hang out
at several amusement parks and stay at a
hotel where the alleged abuse occurred
still ahead on law and crime daily real
estate air robert durst on trial
while there's another pause in the
testimony but first
the defense of a colorado man calls into
question the state's cadaver dogs
but is the evidence more bark than bite
you decide
next
[Music]
welcome back an expert calls into
question the reliability of the dogs
used
to search for dylan redwine after he
went missing
law and crime's angela levy is here with
what an expert in animal behavior
said in mark redwine's trial brian this
zoologist said that these dogs can
oftentimes do things
simply to pro to please their handlers
and he faced a pretty tough
cross-examination by prosecutors
dr james haw testified on behalf of mark
redwine
answering questions about why a search
dog may not have picked up a scent to
track dylan redwine
off of something from his dad's house
but did get a scent from items from his
mother's home
with the pillow from dad's house even if
it had been
used by dylan have been perceived
differently by the dogs than the items
from mom's house
it's my opinion that there's a very
strong chance that would be true yes
prosecutors have implied dylan redwine
died before he had a chance to use the
pillow at his dad's house
that was given to a dog to pick up his
scent a cadaver dog indicated the scent
of death and mark redwine's truck
in his home and on mark redwine's
clothing but he said the dogs detect
decomposition of skin cells and other
bodily fluids
can you say with a reasonable degree of
scientific certainty
whether ms corcoran gumming's dog was
sensing a dead body
or something else in mr red wine's house
109 days after dylan went missing
i i cannot say that dr haas said he
believed the cadaver dogs results were
inconclusive when it came to whether a
dead body had come into contact
with mark redwine's clothing or truck
because of the amount of time that had
passed
prosecutors questioned his credentials
you have no certified
human remains detection handling
experience correct that's correct
dr haw conceded he has no expertise in
how
search or cadaver dogs are trained and
certified nor had he seen the dog's work
i am addressing the science the value of
the
evidence from the scientific point of
view
on basic principles of dog cognition and
learning
now dr ha agreed that dogs have a much
better sense of smell than people do and
they can simply pick up things that
people cannot but he also
seemed skeptical of some claims by other
experts
that the scent of decomposition can
remain for as long as 660 days
after remains are moved from a location
and there was a question about whether
the dogs could still pick up that scent
the prosecution says they can the
defense skeptical about that
brian thanks internet let's bring back
criminal defense attorney bernardo
villalona
and terry austin to discuss dog
detection anjanet
dr ha talked about cueing what did he
mean by that
you know he was trying to say that you
know a dog might do something that its
owner wants it to do say you put the dog
by the truck
well maybe the dog will go over to the
truck and get really excited
because he feels that his handler or his
owner wants him to do that so that they
are rewarded
so he was trying to say that maybe there
were some queuing involved
in this investigation by the cadaver dog
and possibly even
a search dog but the prosecution really
questioned him about that and as you
heard he said he doesn't really have any
expertise on how these dogs are trained
uh or how they are certified it's almost
like a false positive a dog is supposed
to cue or sit down when they detect
something
maybe they do that just to please their
owner and not actually detect the
substance
i could see that no but terry did the
defense's expert create any reasonable
doubt
in these pooches performance i did think
there was
some doubt created although he kept
saying that he's this animal behavior
expert and not
a canine detection expert so that really
discredits
most of what he had to say but what
angenette said really makes sense a dog
queues because they might be pointed in
a certain direction so there's some
doubt because the jury's probably
thinking hmm that's probably correct
and he also talked about this residual
odor i thought that made sense as well
that how could it last for so long but
on the other hand the prosecution said
we know for a fact that molly this dog
did
cue or point to a particular indication
many many days after the fact so i don't
know
it's some doubt but is it reasonable
doubt yeah bernardo there seems to be
some back and forth did the defense's
experts survive the prosecution's
cross-examination at the end of the day
though
no not at all the prosecution did an
excellent job in cross-cross examining
this
expert especially when the prosecution
points it out
that this expert never looked at any of
the training of this dog
to see whether this dog was equipped to
do these types of tests or what
background painting of his handler so i
think
without having looked at that the expert
did lose
credibility in terms of all the opinions
that he formed
all right we'll see how the credibility
of this witness continues as
law and crime covers the mark redwine
trial and now to check
in on our other ongoing trial at the law
and crime network
court is now on break on monday for
robert durst as some of the jurors have
other appointments
the real estate heir is accused of
shooting his best friend susan berman
in december 2000. prosecutors are still
calling witnesses
as the month-long trial progresses last
week attorneys were reading transcripts
from durst's 2003
galveston texas trial for the death of
his neighbor morris black
testimony is set to resume on tuesday
coming up on law on crime daily foiled
attack on the mlb all-star game
or drug and gun bus the denver police
raid that found a small arsenal of steps
from a stadium
plus a public records request in the
bronx taylor case
could the louisville metro police
department have lied about body cam
video evidence
a family's lawsuit next welcome back
a new lawsuit has been filed in the
briana taylor case
the attorney for her family is now
claiming police lied about the existence
of body cam video
from the deadly raid and is demanding
the department hand it over
attorney sam aguiar claims the attorneys
at breach taylor's door
had been issued body cameras that would
have turned on automatically
he's now asking a judge to compel the
louisville metro police department
to disclose and produce public records
of the audit trial logs
for the cameras aguirre helped taylor's
family reach a 12 million dollar
wrongful death settlement
with the city taylor was shot and killed
inside her apartment last march
aguiar says six of the officers were
issued body cams
local news have reported officer miles
cosgrove was photographed wearing a
mounting bracket
for a body camera without the actual
camera being attached
another officer anthony james has stated
on the record
that he failed to turn on his own camera
and that the other officers were not
wearing theirs
joining us to discuss the latest
surrounding the death of brianna taylor
is criminal defense attorney bernardo
violona and co-host terry austin
terry this looks like another attempt to
get video the taylor family believes
exists
could this answer whether or not there
is a video in this case
it really could brian i mean the family
and the public for that matter
deserve to know the entire situation and
if there's more body cam
they need to be able to see that so
they're bringing this action
under the open records act in kentucky
which basically says
that any person can make a request to
see
public records and if that request is
denied
they can bring in action to get those
records to them so
i think it's a shame that we have to
have another lawsuit it's a waste of
public dollars
but i think they have every right to
bring that action so we can see the full
picture
bernard break it down so we can see the
full picture does this mean there is
video out there
and if so what could the implications be
so what we're looking at if there is
video that is out there
we're not sure we don't know obviously a
lot happened that night that we
still don't know however what this
action is forcing the government to
actually do
is to put on the record is there more
video out there
present us with the audio trail to see
if we can actually
track those body camera and if there is
let's see what happens would the
prosecutor's office step in
and going to present the case to the
grand jury we don't know we know we
didn't get that from daniel cameron
but who's to say he'll be the ag at the
next election because remember there is
no statute of limitation
when it comes to homicide yeah so a lot
to figure out here this could give
us so much more information where we
have so little when it comes to that to
briana taylor
thank you everyone for your input when
we come back not all heroes wear
capes some full towels provide room
service and help make major drug and gun
busts
the new kind of heroes you don't want to
miss next
welcome back the suspect accused in a
triple shooting that ended on a georgia
golf course
is being held in jail without bond
brian rhoden is facing three counts of
murder three counts of aggravated
assault
and two counts of kidnapping police in
georgia say roden killed two men
bounding their hands and legs and mouths
with tape then
put their bodies in the bed of a pickup
truck rhoden is then accused of driving
onto a golf course
and fatally shooting golf pro gene
siller rhoden has not yet entered a plea
we have recovered weapons and we have
recovered
narcotics anything beyond that
speculating
as to what an individual's intent is
we can't do that we can't do that denver
police remain tight-lipped
on the motive of the three men and one
woman facing drug and weapons charges
arrested inside of a hotel just steps
away from coors field
it happened friday night ahead of this
week's major league baseball's
all-star game an initial media report
cites one source who said police feared
an incident
similar to the deadly mass shooting at a
las vegas music festival in 2017.
but now kmgh tv reports police recovered
16 long guns and more than 1 000 rounds
of ammunition and a possible trade of
drugs and weapons
denver officials credit a maid at the
maven hotel for alerting authorities
several news outlets report the maid
spotted one of the guns in a room
trust just a drug deal and a gun deal
don't worry those are words i never
thought i would say but here we are
bernarda you're a former prosecutor how
do you investigate this case
to make sure it's about guns and drugs
and not about an attack on the mlb
all-star game
so brian the way to start is definitely
collecting the cell phones and i'm sure
that the prosecution actually the
government has already
taken the cell phones and getting search
warrants for those cell phones and start
tracking what the messages are
as well as the history as to where these
parties have been
prior to getting to that location in
addition to that
is their social media presence as well
as gps locations for the vehicle that
they may have traveled to that location
there's so much that they can do it's
just going to take a little bit of time
in order to get the information but i'm
sure that the government will be able to
see
in a matter of days exactly what was
being planned for that specific day
was it a gun deal drug deal or was it a
planned massacre
yeah and i'm sure that the defense is
probably gonna want to participate to
the fullest extent
to ensure that it's a gun and drug deal
rather than terrorist charters those are
very different
now terry they bring you coffee in the
morning they clean your linens
and it seems they also make major crime
busts these housekeepers seem to be able
to do it all right
you know what brian you cannot
underscore
the importance of if you see something
say something and that's exactly what
this individual did and just seeing the
gun alarmed her and the volume the sheer
volume 16 long guns and 1 000 rounds of
ammunition
that is really frightening and as
bernard said
and she correctly said this they are
going to look
at all social media they're going to
look at the telephones
and we did see that on facebook there
was one post
that said he was going to go out for one
of the defendants
in a big way so you have to wonder what
was being planned was it just a gun deal
or was there something else that was
planned
all right so as we said there are three
men and one woman arrested thanks
to the tip from a housekeeper in a hotel
and quick thinking from the police
officers bernard terry thank you very
much for joining us here at long crime
daily
and thank you for joining us here as
always we'll see you next time as we
discuss
justice in america
[Music]
[Music]
you